[Musique]
oh
bonsoir merci d'être avec nous sur
france 3 la chaîne de la proximité des
élections municipales pour notre grande
soirée de débat du mercredi des débats
pour tout savoir pour faire votre choix
avec les arguments les programmes les
convergences et les désaccords
avant la commune de nevers dans une
petite cinquantaine de minutes place à
notre premier débat de la soirée avec
chalon la première ville de saône et
loire
un débat que j'ai le plaisir d'animer
avec thomas nous gagnons de france bleu
bonsoir comme un bon soir l'ue liant
bonsoir à tous
chalon sur saône sous préfecture de
saône et loire un peu plus de quarante
six mille habitants
c'est la quatrième ville de bourgogne
franche comté derrière dijon besançon et
belfort
chalon dirigé depuis 2014 par gilles
platret est aussi une ville de sport une
ville de culture avec l'élan son club de
basket ou encore avec son festival
chalon dans la rue mais chalon c'est
également une dette très importante que
la ville traîne comme un boulet depuis
des années alors dans ce contexte
comment être ambitieux pour chalon ses
habitants ses commerces
comment la préparer à affronter le
changement climatique ces quelques uns
des enjeux de ces municipales est avec
nous sur ce plateau six têtes de listes
bonjour nathalie leblanc dans ça vous
mener la liste soutenue par le ps vous
étiez adjointe lors du mandat précédent
christophe sirugue de 2008 à 2014
bonjour gilles d'après ans où vous êtes
le maire sortant les républicains de
chalon sur saône élu au premier tour il
y a 6 ans candidat donc à une réélection
et alain rousseau payet bonsoir vous
mener la liste l'arrêt de la république
en marche vous étiez précédemment maire
de châtenoy en bresse
bonsoir mourra de la wes vous êtes prof
de maths conseiller municipal
d'opposition vous êtes écologistes et
vous mener la liste europe écologie les
verts si pâle une liste écologie les
verts c'est une soutenue par europe
ecologie les verts citoyenne alors
bonsoir bonsoir que ma bonsoir isabelle
de choc candidate sans étiquette vous
avez été première adjointe au maire
gilles platret jusqu'en 2015
vous avez démissionné de ce poste suite
au dossier des menus de substitution au
sujet desquels vous étiez en désaccord
avec avec le maire enfin bon soir franck
diop
bonsoir vous êtes chef d'entreprise et
vous mener la liste du rassemblement
national ajoutant que pascal dufresne il
mène aussi une liste pour lutte ouvrière
nous lui donnerons la parole un peu plus
tard dans ce débat un débat qui va duré
une quarantaine de minutes avec trois
thèmes et pour chacun d'entre vous une
conclusion d'une minute dans l'ordre a
été tiré au sort on commence par notre
premier thème que nous avons intitulé
avec une question la ville de chalon
rayonnante elle encore un thème très
fort à challans qui jusqu aux années
2000 on peut le dire était la ville
dominante en bourgogne
on commencera pas par le maire à qui on
fait devenait vite la parole mais
nathalie leblanc s'était déjà
d'actualité
il y à 12 ans il y a 6 ans cette
question est-ce que c'est inéluctable ou
est-ce que ça dépend des politiques a
rien été rien n'était les nuls table je
voulais faire comme répondre comme brad
est pas une liste du parti socialiste je
suis bien membre du parti socialiste
mais c'est une liste de gauche qui
rassemble d'autres partis et des membres
qui ne sont pas encartés non plus alors
vous avez vos étiquettes juste pour
avoir on essaie aussi d'être clair pour
les gens qui nous regardent n'y ait pas
de la région mon coeur est à voir dans
je suis bien membre du parti socialiste
sur la liste n'est pas une liste
socialiste chalon rayonne t-elle encore
c'est effectivement une question
extrêmement extrêmement intéressante
ce que je note en tout cas depuis depuis
plusieurs années maintenant et en tout
cas très nettement depuis 2014 c'est que
l'image de notre ville s'est dégradée ce
chat l'ont été
la réputation d'une ville accueillante
d'une ville très forte culturellement et
la question effectivement de la fin des
menus de substitution a fait que l'on a
parlé de manière extrêmement négative de
notre ville
nationalement la baisse du soutien à la
des crédits à la culture fait qu'on ne
parle d'ailleurs plus nationalement de
chalon dans la rue ce qui est positif
et puis j'y reste sur le sur le commerce
par exemple c'est vrai qu'on a un centre
ville qui dépérit avec un taux de
vacance se tissent accélère on est au
delà de 2 18% donc on peut penser
effectivement qu'il ya des inquiétudes
pour cette ville pour autant je ne suis
pas négative et chalon sur saône est une
ville vraiment qu'il ya du resort qui a
toujours su se sortir des grandes
difficultés dans lesquelles dans
lesquelles elle se trouve à un moment
j'étais au 35e alors oslo payet
concernant la vacance commercial vous
vous trouvez également qu'il ya des gros
sociale oui enfin pour une grosse plus
humbles apporta fait pour eux
effectivement une acquisition
il est clair que chalon souffre jaloux
souffrent parce que effectivement depuis
maintenant pas mal d'années il ya eu
beaucoup d'accidents industriels à
chalon et il est clair aussi qu'au cours
des six dernières années on a notamment
la problématique effectivement du
centre-ville qui qui en fait le jas dire
un peu stigmatise un petit peu cette
souffrance et souffrances de chalon
actuel par rapport à son centre vient
cette vacance aujourd'hui effectivement
la vacance du centre-ville de chalon ce
à peu près 22 % de vacances 1 sur la
ville quand on voit que les taux
nationaux son tour de 10 à 12% donc on
voit qu'il ya un vrai problème par
rapport à chalon au niveau de cette
vacance commercial j'ai vu l'attrait
culture vacances commerciale quelle
sombre tableau avant toute chose un
regret ne me l'ait c'est que nous ne
soyons que six autour de la table vous
allez me je voulais le dire vous savez
qu'on a eu des échanges à ce sujet je
pense qu'on aurait pu mettre à cette
septième place je suis pas à partisans
des théories développées par monsieur
dufresne je pense qu'il aurait dû être
là voilà je le dis pour la qualité des
bas démographique
déjà nécessaire je vous rappelle juste
les critères d'équité du csa qui nous
laisse maître de la dimension éditoriale
de ce débat que nous avons appliqué
strictement proposant pas ce qu'il
entend bien d'intervenir sec mais
n'empêche que ça aurait quand même été
utile nous semble-t-il qu'ils puissent
avoir la main je vous propose qu'on soit
chacun dans notre rôle nous dans
l'organisme du débat vous dans le rôle
de maire et candidat votre mais surtout
dans le rôle d'un candidat qui veut
débattre avec les autres candidats et
qui pourrait effectivement dépeindre la
situation un petit peu d'une manière
moins sombre que ce qu'ils viennent nous
échouons je vous réponde à répondre à
nos questions voilà donc vous m'avez
mauvais théorie sur le rayonnement le
rayonnement c'est bon t'as de répondre
surtout bien sûr c'est le rayonnement
c'est une ville qui regagne des
habitants les recensements d'année en
année nous montre que nous regagnons des
habitants c'est une ville qui regagne
des emplois nous avons réussi même si
encore du travail chacun le sait à faire
baisser notre taux de chômage on était
au début du mandat à plus de 9% on est
aujourd'hui à 7 6% c'est encore 7 6% de
trop on vient encore d'installer une
entreprise aujourd'hui même qui s'est
promis de créer 300 emplois
donc il y avait raison d'espérer bien
sûr qu'il ya des difficultés comme
beaucoup de villes moyennes en
connaissent mais dépeindre un tableau si
noir ne correspond pas à la réalité qui
est vécue sur le terrain par les
chalonnaises et les chalonnais de chaud
sur ce sujet évidemment que le tableau
n'est pas si noir que ça on voit que la
difficulté en fait et surtout d'aller
chercher de manière équilibrée des
emplois qui sont créés mais qui sont des
emplois qui nécessite peu de
qualifications et donc avec un des bas
salaires et la nécessité d'aller
retrouver une attractivité de ce
territoire pour des entreprises qui vont
créer des postes de cadres parce que
c'est quand même ça dont il va s'agir
c'est comment on fait pour faire revenir
des cadres et donc des familles parce
que certes la ville de gagne
en terme de démographie regagne en terme
de démographie mais le département ne
gagne pas en terme de démographie et des
villes qui sont pas très loin sur l'est
sur l'ouest du département en perdent
donc ça veut dire quoi concrètement ça
veut dire que on a des seniors qui
reviennent sur des pôle de centralité
parce qu'il ya des services alors les
seniors c'est très très bien ça
participe aussi l'attractivité de notre
ville et elle son développement mais ça
n'est pas suffisant et je crois qu'ils
en auraient tout intérêt dans le terme
de développement économique mais qui est
plutôt un sujet d'agglomération pour le
coup qu un sujet purement municipal nous
aurions tout intérêt à nous rapprocher
de l'ouest du département
parce que là bas nous avons un bassin
industriel sur lesquels nous pourrions
trouver des complémentarités de
territoire et donc une attractivité
supplémentaire pour ne pas se retrouver
coincé entre le nord de la bourgogne et
le sud qui est quand même du département
qui est très attiré par la région
lyonnaise il faut pas se cacher derrière
son petit doigt
franck diop je vous vois a cassé à ce
que d abel de cheveux je suis à caen et
cette analyse je suis je suis d'accord
avec l'analyse que ma camarade vient de
faire c'est limpide et je pense surtout
que par delà sa chalon était comme on va
dire le phare de 2,2 d'un département où
le phare de la bresse c'était quand même
quelque chose d'important
on venait à chalon pour pour aller
récupérer chercher les choses qu'on ne
trouvait même pas à dijon ou parfois
même pas à lyon et comme com com com
comme l'a dit ma camarade encore une
fois le fait est que il ya quand même
des choses à redévelopper redynamiser
cette ville pour que tout simplement
elle puisse redevenir le phare qu'elle
était et je pense qu'il ya un travail de
fond à faire avec tout toutes les
entités qui ont composé justement cette
ville les jeunes les moins jeunes les
quartiers réintégrer aussi les quartiers
au sens au sein de la ville je pense
qu'il ya un travail de symbiose à
recréer et je pense que justement yahia
une qualité de travail d'emploi qui
étaient apportées à chalon
qui justement peut-être nécessite aussi
une réflexion puisque encore une fois
c'est vrai que les emplois qualifiés de
manque réellement dans cette ville mais
comment vous faites pas dans cette liste
de voeux pieux mais concrètement et à
après moi je prends l'exemple de
certaines villes comme nantes tout
simplement à l'instar de ces villes là
qu'est ce qu'elles ont fait elles ont
été chercher des gens qui étaient des
professionnels justement qui équivaut
qui ont été investis pour la recherche
d'entreprises de capitaux et qui ont
ramené justement des entreprises avec
avec une belle visibilité internationale
justement pour la plupart du temps dans
dans leur ville je pense que c'est une
chose qu'il faut adapter à chalon c'est
quelque chose qui peut être justement
vecteur non seulement d'emplois
qualifiés
chalon a tout à fait la capacité
d'accueil aussi bien des familles que de
que justement de la redistribution de
l'arrière-pays je vous comprends pas
besoin de manger toi moi de l'ouest est
ce que l'avenir leur rayonnement de
chalon c'est des entreprises ou dans
votre position dans la liste que vous
mais peut-être d'autres voies non je
voudrais d'abord dire monsieur plein de
trucs
le tableau n'est pas si sombre que ça
même s'il n'est pas non plus le
dramatique il est vrai que j'ai il faut
bien reconnaître qu'il ya quand même un
taux de chômage important
donc j'allais chez free si je crois
qu'il est de 26 selon l'insee et de 7,6
selon loi j'ai pris un porte pas saoul
il est vrai aussi que sur le plan de
l'attractivité chalon elle perd des
habitants par rapport aux grands
changements sur le grand chalon ou
dernier un peu plus navré mais voilà
donc pourquoi il faut aussi savoir une
chose c'est que
la traque tv l'attractivité
pardonnez-moi d'une ville ne se mesure
pas seulement par ses commerces
même si le commerce effectivement et en
difficulté à chalon il se mesure aussi
par l'attractivité par le bien-être et
la qualité de vie des habitants
nous avons des chalonnais qui sont
créatifs et talentueux
nous avons une ville qui a beaucoup
d'atouts touristiques économiques
ça c'est vrai et finalement ce qu'on
demande à une ville pour être attractif
c'est de plaire aux habitants qui sue et
d'attirer d'autres habitants donc avoir
une bonne qualité de vie c'est-à-dire
déjà une ville qui est prête à relever
le défi climatique
avoir une vie l'embellie avoir de la
végétalisation ville avoir de l'emploi
bien entendu donc avoir aussi des
cantines où l'on sert des repas
préférence bio avec des repas
végétariens
par conséquent ce qui attire les
médecins ce qui attire les entreprises
qui ont des familles c'est de se trouver
bien dans la ville où ils vous pour
venir
oui d'accord non non je vous fais tous
des réponses très très très très longue
et au final personne n'aura bref en
échange être activé à l'argument du
commun on aura bien compris et je
voulais redonner un tout petit peu de
temps à la rousseau payet sur ce sujet
parce qu'il avait parlé très brièvement
tout à l'heure vous avez parlé du
centre-ville mais la bolivie en général
et si je voudrais répondre à monsieur
platret par rapport à cela parce que
effectivement quand on compare notre
activité on parle on mélange à la fois
le grand chez look et l'agglomération de
50 et une commune et puis la ville et je
crois à monsieur platret ce qu'il faut
vraiment aujourd'hui et demain
il faut qu'on sépare bien les choses et
je pense qu'il faut qu'on pose vraiment
le bilan de la ville et campements
d'attractivité il faut bien parler de
l'attractivité de la ville de la ville
centre par rapport à l'agglomération
l'agglomération comme vous savez je la
connais bien j'ai siégé effectivement
donc et pas de souci par rapport à cela
simplement l'agglomération à une
politique qui est la sienne dans le cas
de ses attributions
li centre est elle même comme les autres
communes à sa propre sa propre politique
pour mener une propre attractif sa
propre activité attractivité donc c'est
ça qui est important et je crois que
c'est là un moment donné au coût de ces
six ans on a l'impression que c'est
toujours en clair que vous cachez un
petit peu derrière l'agglomération donc
moi je vous dise forte de
l'agglomération et assumer en tant que
maire et premier magistrat de la ville
votre fonction de maire et de bilan et
de l'attractivité chalonnaise de
retraite l'apprendre enchaîne ce pas
votre réponse parce qu'en fait on est
entièrement d'accord que la ville s'en
fait partie intégrante d'ailleurs vous
avez été maire d'une commune à côté de
chalon sur saône jusqu'à date très
récente très récentes pascal afin
d'aller vers un même début de cette
année et par conséquent vous savez très
bien comment ça fonctionne sur la ville
centre
un rôle éminent ma condition travaillant
à la coopération et cette coopération ne
peut s'envisager que si l'agglomération
travail en intelligence avec l'ensemble
des communes
il me semble que c'est ce qu' avec
sébastien martin à la tête de
l'agglomération nous avons fait pendant
six années j'ai souvenir dans un mandat
précédent que les relations entre la
ville centre et les communes n'étaient
pas si harmonieuse qu'elles le sont
aujourd'hui
donc la question de l'attractivité on ne
se cache pas derrière l'agglomération on
la travaille ensemble sur rousselot
payet et comme comment peut-on dire
qu'il faut séparer la ville de
l'agglomération
il faut que les deux travaillent
ensemble pour l'attractivité de tout le
territoire
une ville sans dynamique dans une agglo
dynamique c'est exactement ce que nous
avons fait ce que nous proposons de
faire six années ont retrouvé il faut
trouver le bon équilibre
c'était il y aurait été trouvé mais
s'était facilement avec ça s'est
équilibré passe en ce moment et et il
faut que la ville centre
il faut que la ville s'en prennent
effectivement soit la locomotive d'un
rang supérieur à l'attractivité et quand
on parle puisque je reviens la première
question sur l'attractivité du
centre-ville
et quand on parle de vacances commercial
sa porte bien sur la ville et c'est là
où la vie doit avoir un rôle moteur avec
le premier magistrat de la ville entre
autres et son équipe puisse agir par
rapport à de telles actions
et c'est pas l'agglomération qui peut
venir constamment excusez moi pour
secours de la ville mais les opérations
inter communal est d'ailleurs le grand
chalon c'est une coopération
intercommunale très clairement
voilà mais il faut trouver le bon
équilibre il faut que chacun trouve sa
place avait très bien que si la ville
sans elle même n'avait pas à consolider
son attractivité l'agglomération ne s'y
seraient pas retrouvés
plus donc arrêter d'opposer l'un à
l'autre il faut travailler au contraire
l'un avec l'autre
c'était une abstention petit
l'intercours passe à la suite on passait
là pour parler de la suite
oui deuxième thème de notre grand débat
ce soir
quand on parle de chalon on parle d'une
ville de deauville même de plusieurs
villes challans est une ville qui a
plusieurs quartiers avec des grosses
d'identité des quartiers très pauvres
essayé d'écarter un peu plus riches
est-ce que vous avez l'impression
nathalie leblanc que sept quartiers ont
tous été traités sur le même pied
d'égalité
durant le mal pour commencer je vois
comment s'y prendre la parole
au départ je trouve qu'on ne peut pas
séparer les politiques menées par le
grand chalon et les politiques qui sont
menées par la ville de chalon sur saône
quand on pense aux transports urbains
quand on pense à l'habitat quand on
pense à l'économie en général
l'environnement c'est effectivement très
imbriquées et les décisions qui ont été
prises durant cette mandature par le
grand chalon l'on était évidemment par
la majorité de la ville de chalon sur
saône dans ce débat quand on parle du
rayonnement de la ville de chalon sur
saône moi je pense qu'il faut
s'intéresser aux habitants de chalon sur
saône et pas simplement à l'attractivité
de la ville et est ce que les politiques
qui sont menées correspondent aux
problématiques des habitants de notre
ville clairement non vous avez vous avez
déclaré le lien social et déliter oui
j'ai clairement dit le lien social et
déliter tout simplement parce qu'on a vu
une des crédits qui ont été
majoritairement mise sur le centre ville
sur la ville centre des quartiers qui
ont été ou qui ont été délaissés
j'ai repris le budget 2010 9 le budget
2010 neuf c'était 4 millions pour le
centre ville c'était 615 millions pour
tous les autres quartiers
donc il ya vraiment un déséquilibre
autre élément il faut répondre aux
problématiques des chalonnaises et des
chalonnais nous avons parlé du taux de
chômage qui reste qu'on est important il
ya quand même beaucoup de personnes qui
sont éloignés de l'emploi
on a construit des immeubles à chalon
qui sont dix immeubles très cher un t2
dans le quartier la sucrerie
c'est de ces cent cinquante mille euros
c'est beaucoup trop cher pour la
population chalonnaise
en même temps on a arrêté le programme
de rénovation urbaine dont qui venait en
aide aux plus précaires d'entre nous
donc est ce qu'il y à du fils louis on
voit très clairement effectivement que
de vie elle se dessine chalon sur saône
et qu'on ne répond pas à la
problématique de la totalité des
habitants de cette ville
le show à manger très envie de vous de
vous renvoyer dos à dos et les uns et
les autres tout simplement parce que sur
sous la mandature madame de 2002 8 à
2014 certes il y avait un très gros
effort de fait au profit et j'ai presque
envie de dire au seul et unique profite
d'un guide des quartiers prioritaires de
la ville de chalon qui obérait
absolument la suite du développement
équilibré de chalon sur saône
et puis sur cette mandature la celle
inverse l'accent a été mis sur l'hyper
centre en gros sur les quais de saône et
à terme sur l'île saint laurent et je
crois que le vrai des filles de la
mandature à venir ça va être de
rééquilibrer l'intégralité des
investissements sur cette ville parce
qu'il y avait énormément de demandes
dans tous les quartiers et quand on
parle de quartier c'est pas simplement
les trois quartiers prioritaires de la
ville de chalon sur saône
mais ce sont tous les quartiers de la
ville y compris ceux de la du
centre-ville quand on parle de sécurité
etc
je ferai quand même qu'on y pense et il
va falloir rééquilibrer tout ça re
donner de la lisibilité
parce que le lien se dévide pourquoi
parce que des chaînes et ont
l'impression d'être moins bien traités
que d'autres et c'est par cette
lisibilité là et c'est par le fait
qu'ils vont pouvoir se réapproprier tous
ces dossiers là qu'on va pouvoir recréer
du lien entre les uns et les autres de
manière équilibrée sur l'ensemble de
notre territoire
on parle le rééquilibrage vers équilibré
aussi le propos bien sûr que des
investissements ont été consentis sur le
centre ville le centre ville c'est le
quartier le seul quartier qui soit
commun à tous les chalonnais
on y va pour ses courses on y va pour
ses démarches administratives on y va
pour profiter les bords de la saône
il y avait un certain nombre
d'investissements qui devait être fait
on avait repoussé depuis des années le
réaménagement de nos quais et l'image de
la ville c'est l'agrément pour ses
habitants c'est aussi pouvoir profiter
sa rivière donc nous avons entamé le
chantier et nous proposons d'ailleurs de
le poursuivre pour avoir le grand
continuum des quais depuis le quartier
sainte-marie jusque aux portes de chalon
qui sont en train d'être qualifié par le
grand chalon là aussi on a besoin des
deux nous avons la même façon nous
disent à la lime à une réponse à la
différence budget justement voilà alors
la différence de budget je j'entends les
la statistique qui viennent nous est
donné on a énormément investi dans les
quartiers peut-être qu'on n'a pas
forcément la même notion la même
définition du périmètre des quartiers
quand la ville de chalon décide de
consacrer ce qui n'était pas arrivé
depuis des lustres et des lustres un
million d'euros chaque année à la
rénovation de ces écoles
elle le fait prioritairement dans les
écoles qui ne sont pas dans le centre
quand on investit alors je vais le dire
avec le grand chalon mais on n'a pas à
se cacher puisque nous avons tous voté
au profit des habitants de chalon
ces investissements quand on décide
d'investir sur des espaces petite
enfance et espace multi-accueil dans les
quartiers on ne travaille pas pour le
centre nous avons rénové les quêtes
source
nous avons rénové également des secteurs
proches du sang qui n'avait pas été
rénovée depuis une soixantaine d'années
le quartier de la citadelle d'un côté le
quartier pasteur de l'autre qu'on nous
reproche cela ça me paraît aberrant
parce qu'une ville a besoin justement
d'investissement dans tous les quartiers
que les chalonnais aille sur le terrain
et que vous y alliez aussi un petit peu
vous ne pouvez pas dire que rien n'a été
fait pour les quartiers de chalon c'est
impossible parce que c'est contraire à
la vérité
vous êtes d'accord avec son amoureux de
l'ouest les quartiers n'ont pas été
abandonnées à chalon sur saône
non je ne suis pas d'accord parce que si
le comité de pilotage de
des quartiers de la ville qui le dit
lui-même de la politique du contrat de
ville qu'elle dit lui même
les habitants des quartiers les aubépins
les prés saint jean et les stades
fontaine au loup se sentent délaissés
donc c'est pas moi c'est vraiment le
comité de pilotage tu le dis je le
rappelais d'ailleurs en plein conseil
municipal
mais par ailleurs ce qu'il faudrait
certes il y a peut-être vous avez
peut-être fait quelque chose mais on
voit aujourd'hui que ce n'est pas
efficace puisque on à ce résultat
et quant aux aménagements au centre
ville une des raisons pour lesquelles
les gens se sentent délaissés ou
inconsidérées c'est justement le fait
qu'on impose des projets de manière
verticale
ce serait quand même bien d'avoir un peu
plus de concertation sur beaucoup de
projets sur apache est un loup gaulle
sur de l'aménagement des quais sur la
rue de la citadelle
or aujourd'hui on a un plan cyclable
piétons inexistant on à la
végétalisation fort peu développé voir
on a quelques quelques arbres coupés
alors qu'on devrait employer plus je
sais ce que vous allez dire vous avez
monté 60 ha bon voilà je préfère que
vous répondiez je voudrais une égalité
des cartes réalisées
l'inégalité existe mais dans votre
question on parle aussi en principe des
infrastructures donc voilà ça fait donc
je vous le dis donc on a besoin d'eux
finalement pour les inégalités entre les
quartiers on a besoin de remettre
véritablement de l'humain de l'humain
sur le terrain ça marche engager des
médiateurs des îlotiers des policiers
ils s'engagent sur ce sujet c'est vrai
que remet de l'humain se ferait pas de
mal on voit clairement que dans
différentes parties de la ville
il ya un vrai manque justement de 2,2
symbiose grosso modo quand on voit
certains quartiers des quartiers on veut
dire lebdi les plus sensibles on a
l'impression d'être totalement coupés de
la ville d totalement dans un dans un
autre monde d'études quelque temps dans
des endroits qui sont un peu à part tout
simplement parce que je pense que depuis
des décennies malheureusement de
monsieur plâtré
et aussi un peu n'est pas responsable
mais en tout cas c'est que ces trente
quarante dernières années c'est car ces
quartiers-là ont été totalement
humainement délaissé humainement d'art
donnez moi si je vous dis que je suis
surprise d'argumentaire qui n'est pas
celui de votre partie habituellement sur
ce sujet là après ce énième parler de
sécurité vous savez le quartier c'est un
fin de partie pardon c'est un fait mais
la réalité c'est le plus important
aujourd'hui
effectivement il ya un mois le fait en
politique il ya quand même des arguments
tout est bien tout à faire la sécurité
la biodiversité le comment faire en
sorte d'intégrer le centre ville de
chalon dans les quartiers je pense que
justement les gens qui sont dans ces
quartiers-là aimerait un peu plus
intégrée dans le débat citoyen pour
avoir leur mot à dire sur justement la
régénération globale de leur quartier
que ce soit encore une fois au niveau du
verre au niveau des pistes cyclables au
niveau de l'emploi et l'avidité de la
localité de la sécurité bien évidemment
tout ça hein tout le jeu bien je parle
bien mais il ya des ya des sujets qui
sont tellement importants et qui sont
tous à mettre sur le même pied d'égalité
qu'il ne faut pas négliger un pour
justement de travailler sur d'autres
c'est ce qui fait justement qu'il ya un
tel un tel fossé que aujourd'hui on se
pose cette question là parce qu'encore
une fois s'il n'y avait pas eu toutes
ces choses qui ont été à dire mis un peu
de côté ces quartiers là aujourd'hui
ferait intégralement partie du centre
eure 1 du centre de chalon c'est mon
point de vue il faut un pont entre le
centre le centre de chalon et ces
quartiers là pour que les gens des
libyens la retravailler sur ce sujet
alors écoutez le sujet des quartiers
c'est vraie question qui était déjà
présent dans le débat c'est à dire six
ans et bien sûr et fait déjà un an plus
tôt comme quoi si on en reparle encore
pour cette campagne est orale c'est
qu'il ya un vrai sujet d'ailleurs c'est
pour ça que notre liste s'appelle
ensemble parce qu'effectivement il y à
14 quartiers sur la ville et
effectivement il y a un vrai sentiment
nous vois quand on va sur le terrain on
doit quand on va sur le terrain c'est
que les gens nous disent nous sommes
délaissés n'y a rien eu de fait pour les
quartiers et donc ça c'est pas une
question de chiffres c'est un vrai
ressenti
et quand on parle de ça il faut l'aide
l'attribué à différentes politiques
toutes les politiques publiques qui sont
liées à la ville soit au niveau des
transports et transport effectivement
c'est le grand show
mais la ville de chalon doit aussi dire
son mot par rapport à cela et doit avoir
conscience que quelquefois dans les
quartiers les lélés nos habitants sont
demandeurs de transport que quand on va
dans le quartier qu'est ce qu'on nous
dit bah on nous dit voilà il ya
effectivement des navettes gratuites et
centre-ville mais il n'a pas dans les
quartiers donc ça c'est un vrai sujet et
là on nous dit on et délaissée ça c'est
sur la question des transports
l'autre question c'est la question
effectivement de la sécurité la sécurité
au lit il ya eu effectivement une
politique mais tu es mené en matière de
sécurité par exemple la
vidéosurveillance et je trouve que sur
cet aspect là puisque tout est rien il
ya des choses qui sont aussi eux
positive et sur la vidéosurveillance qui
est un vrai sujet pour la sécurité nous
sommes favorables à cela puisque c'est
un outil qui aident effectivement à
mettre la sécurité mais là aussi on nous
dit au niveau des quartiers il ya eu
plutôt le sentiment que ça a été fait
sur le centre ville et ont encore une
fois plus et pas d'opposer le centre
ville au quartier puisque c'est la ville
toute entière
voilà ensemble comme je dis souvent lors
des réunions publiques
mais là aussi au niveau des quartiers où
vivent on a l'impression que voilà on a
quelques points pour boucler pourrait
juste pour conclure je termine juste là
dessus que terminer par rapport aux
n'est cependant pas d'écarter c'est
aussi la culture
on y lit aussi on voudrait plus de
culture dans les quartiers qu'elle soit
moins centralisée voilà donc oui je
viens donner trois exemples qui montrent
clairement leurs sentiers de l'ap de nos
habitants au niveau des quartiers ce
délai est et je donne pas rebondi sur
son temps de parole donc sur ce sujet là
à parler de sécurité apparaître culture
dans les quartiers est-ce qu'il vous
semble que ces banques là vous aussi
c'est un constat qui est largement
partagé par la population chalonnaise si
on parle de sécurité très clairement
c'est vrai qu'il ya eu un un accent demi
sous cette mandature sur la sur la
vidéoprotection et c'était un souhait à
l'époque donc c'était bien effectivement
d'y répondre
en revanche aujourd'hui il me paraît
absolument nécessaire de de diligenter
un audit en interne parce que des
caméras qui ont été posées à un moment
donné à l'instant t ne sont peut-être
plus tout à fait aussi pertinente
nous avons tous vu des jeunes
l'un quand narguer des caméras parce
qu'ils savent très exactement comment
tout cela fonctionne donc ça c'est la
première chose et puis redonner un
sentiment de sécurité un sentiment de
lien aussi dans les quartiers ça passe
et en tout cas nous nous en sommes
persuadés à chaque jour chalon ça passe
par la remise en avant de l'îlotage
c'est à dire le fait de permettre à des
policiers municipaux de retourner sur le
terrain énormément d'entre eux sont très
très demandeur à ce sujet là et sans
tomber non plus dans l'exagération du
monsieur plus on va embaucher plus plus
plus plus je crois qu'il faut surtout
avoir une maillage du territoire qu'ils
soient encore une fois équilibrée qui
soit raisonnable qu'ils soient pensées
et leur laisser la possibilité de faire
leur job comme ils savent très bien le
faire en allant au plus près des
habitants au plus près des sorties
d'école au plus près des commerçants
puissent y a pas que des commerces en
centre-ville on a aussi dit le maire
dans les quartiers pour ressentir sa
ville et avoir une
une bonne collaboration entre la police
municipale et la police nationale un mot
un moyen très sûr la sécurité ça cnd a
trimé communication de votre mandat sur
la police municipale surtout des
réalisations du moyen mais c'est normal
quand on parle derrière on a on a pris
une situation où la police était
nécessaire et quel est le retour et
c'est la question nécessaire ça me
fameux permettent peut-être de rétablir
quelques quelques éléments d'après ce
que j'ai entendu même si chacun a le
droit d'avoir évidemment une vision des
choses qui soit différente de celle que
nous portons on a près la situation avec
seize policiers municipaux point de
ville vous l'avez rappelé de
pratiquement quarante sept mille
habitants s'étaient notoirement
insuffisant on avait même une brigade
canine qui ne possédait plus de chiens
ce qui est quand même un peu embêtant
donc on a notre sont seulement d'ôter la
brigade canine de chiens mais surtout
surtout surtout on a commencé un travail
de présence supplémentaire sur le
terrain travail par les effectifs nous
sommes maintenant à 27 policiers
municipaux là où nous étions à 16 au
début du mandat travail
second départ la vidéoprotection qui ne
concerne pas que le centre qui concerne
l'ensemble de chalon cent quarante
caméras aujourd'hui sont en position sur
l'ensemble du territoire chalonnais et
personne n'a narguer les caméras parce
que c'est les policiers qui sont devant
les écrans au centre de supervision
urbain donc ça c'est une vision de
l'esprit complètement
on a pacifié une quartier parce que la
vidéoprotection est arrivé et je
pourrais donner menthe exemple je vais
pas l'amendé particulièrement parce que
on va mal et c'est exactement mais c'est
même le cas ce que nous souhaitons
aujourd'hui c'est poursuivre là dedans
donc intensifier non pas se demander si
on a bien placer les caméras mais au
contraire intensifier le réseau de
vidéoprotection ça c'est une nécessité
qui est vraiment demandée par la
population et commencer à augmenter
sévèrement si je puis dire au
sérieusement les effectifs de la police
municipale en fait on voudrait arriver à
la moyenne des villes de nostra
c'est-à-dire un policier pour 1000
habitants
en gros on est à 27 aujourd'hui il faut
que dans six ans nous savions à 47 qui
nous permettra d'être beaucoup plus
présent sur l'ensemble du territoire
on vient d'ouvrir un bureau de police
municipale aux prés saint jean en étant
on est en train d'en ouvrir un autre aux
aubépins et nous voulons si c'est
nécessaire en ouvrir d'autres dans les
quartiers de la présence sur le terrain
c'est un sujet c'est venu pendant ce
mandat et que vous n'aviez pas choisi de
traiter lors du mandat précédent de la
même manière alors tout d'abord une
réponse quand même à madame de chaume
puisque sur le montat précédent dont
vous parlez nous n'avions absolument pas
abandonner le centre-ville il y avait eu
énormément d'investissement qui avait
été de bhl vous êtes l'heureux un dab
aussi de toutes façons de cette
mandature là puisque c'est vous qui avez
avec monsieur platret arrêté le
programme de rénovation urbaine c'est
vous qui étaient aux responsabilité au
grand chalon et qui avait fait que le
programme de réussite éducative est
passé de 3 119 enfants à 60 enfants et
que les critères effectivement de
politique de la ville comme l'a dit
mourad la white sont désastreux et que
l'on voit que la population se sent
effectivement délaissé dans ces
quartiers et notre volonté à cultivons
chalon c'est de travailler pour toute la
population car nous avons conscience
qu'il y à des personnes en difficulté
également centre-ville donc les
politiques doit s'adresser à l'ensemble
des chalonnaises et des chalonnais et se
remettre de l'humain c'est remettre
alors la vidéoprotection oui c'est vrai
les chalonnais la demande mais pas que
mais pas que c'est un symbiote je le
reconnais mais c'est un simple outil il
faut impérativement ramener de l'humain
dont le sur les terrains de la médiation
notamment de la médiation le soir il
faut ramener de la tranquillité aussi
dans les cas vous n'allez pas me croire
il me reste finalement pas tellement pas
tant que ça
avant d'en arriver aux conclusions un
mot rapide même si elle en moins de
l'ouest me fait les gros yeux parce que
je pense est en train de comprendre ce
que j'ai à dire sur cette dimension
environnementale et sur la ville fasse
est ce que on va ramener un petit peu ça
une question simple parce qu'au match je
prends le j'embraye est ce que c'est le
rôle d'un maire finalement de lutter
contre le réchauffement climatique mois
de l'ouest déjà je regrette que chaque
fois que vous avez un débat de ce genre
l'environnement est toujours à la fin il
reste toujours très peu de temps pour le
faire
c'est la grande zoa les y en a voilà
donc ensuite oui il est de la compétence
du maire c'est même de la responsabilité
du maire parce que le premier devoir du
maire c'est de protéger que deux
personnes vivant sur son territoire et
donc préparé
le territoire préparer la ville contre
le réchauffement climatique l'adapter en
faisant le nécessaire en végétalisant en
en gommant en développant le les plans
cyclables les piétons le plan piéton
sécurisé etc
excusez moi je joue j'essaie un peu de
devoir finalement de vous dire
suffisamment de choses on allemand un
temps très que vous faites résoudre une
équation en exercice n'avait fait ça
voilà donc là dessus sur le grand chalon
non je regrette
malgré ce qu'on peut entendre ici ou là
il n'y a pas eu beaucoup d'avancées
le plan climat énergie territorial
c'était copine vide et nous avons aussi
des gaz à effet de serre la pollution
qui augmente on a aussi des projets qui
les met ici de rue mais bon vous avez
quand même voter on l'a pris parce qu'on
devait le faire c'est pas parce qu'on
est interdite la position est élevé bien
entendu mais je pense que effectivement
pour répondre à votre question de goût
oui c'est de la responsabilité locale
des mers et le aussi des président du
grand chalon donc du grand chalon et de
la ville de lutte et de baies d'apt et
le territoire contre le réchauffement
climatique d'adapter la société est de
faire nécessaire parce que on a
évidemment un problème global qu'ils
sont penser global et de résoudre
localement à la rousselot payet comment
on fait pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique quand on est
maire d'une commune ou qu'il avait été
déplacée longtemps que ça oui tout à
fait mais écoutez je crois que c'est en
matière de d'écologie c'est ce que nous
disons souvent il faut pas une écologie
d'incantation il faut ni l'écologie de
solutions est ce que nous proposons est
à l'échelle d'une ville comme celle de
chalon sur saône et pour agir sur
l'écologie il ya trois leviers que nous
proposons la première c'est les
transports publics puisqu'il faut
effectivement incité les chalonnais
apprendre plus les transports publics
ont la vie chalonnaise est également les
grands chalets pour le coup puisque
c'est eux aussi qu'ils viennent sur la
ville ça c'est une première mesure et on
a des mesures concrètes qu'on n'a pas
trop parlé de mesures concrètes ce sens
c'est un petit peu dommage le temps ne
presse effectivement voilà la deuxième
chose est toujours dans les transports
c'est la mobilité douce
ça a été évoqué tout à l'heure il ya un
vrai plan vélo la ville possède
aujourd'hui une grande discontinuité au
niveau de ces pistes cyclables et même
si elle c'était une compétence
effectivement du grand chalon mais là
c'est encore une fois de plus à la ville
d'impulser cela au centre-ville et ont
son sein et le troisième élément par
rapport à ce que disait monsieur là
ouais c'est effectivement la
visualisation je pense que les à la
ville de futurs en tout cas les deux
futurs c'est celle qui ont une ses
capacités à revitaliser leur place à
créer ce qu'on appelle même ou en termes
de propositions des forêts urbaines et
je pense notamment à l'avenue niépce qui
est une amie relativement important qui
peut être l'épiné dorsale de cette
revitalisation diop
oui moi je souscris tout à fait il faut
carrément essayer de créer un corridor
vert il faut il faut vraiment passer à
quelque chose de 2,2 d'ambitieux parce
que c'est quand même d'autres à venir
sur les vingt trente quarante cinquante
prochaines années
si aujourd'hui une ville ne se dote pas
aujourd'hui d'un vrai plan d'action sur
sur l'environnement je pense qu'elle va
elle va droit dans le mur faut dire ce
qui est donc ça passe au niveau de
l'énergie
ça passe au niveau de la végétalisation
ça passe aussi au niveau juste de 2,1
entre parenthèses la rééducation un peu
des moeurs est d aider des gens je pense
qu'il faut si on passait par là et là où
vous vous posiez la question tout à fait
tout à leur pardon monsieur à ma droite
c'est très important d'en passer
justement par la mairie pour que il
et une transition de ceux de cette
impulsion la au sein de tout de tout
l'est de tous les habitants que tout le
monde se sente à se sentent intégrés
dans la une revisite justement du verre
et des jeux des choses des choses de la
biodiversité
oui c'est la responsabilité du maire et
de l'agglomération puisque la compétence
est partagé entre la ville et
l'agglomération sur ce sujet là bien sûr
tout seul on ne peut que contribuer mais
on peut tout de même contribué
la question a été cité de l'avenue
niépce
il ya trois ans qu'on travaille sur ce
dossier avec un conseil citoyen qui a
vraiment bien travaillé sur ce sujet là
l'idée c'est de l'art qualifier c'est un
gros investissement assez de leurs deux
de plus de 6 millions d'euros
l'estimation en recentrant la
circulation automobile est vraiment en
retraitant les esplanades avec beaucoup
plus de vert nous voulons aussi c'est
inscrit dans le programme végétalisée
l'esplanade de l'espace des arts créer
un jardin temporaire en période estivale
sur la place de deux villes on veut pas
casser les équipements qui a été fait
c'est aussi l'argent du contribuable
mais par contre créé un jardin
temporaire créer trois nouveaux jardins
en centre ville notamment dans le parc
de la banque de france que la ville est
en train d'acheter je vais doit signer
le compromis dans quelques jours et puis
et puis le programme est commencée en
plus pendant ces vacances végétaliser
les cours d'école parce que on se rend
compte que en fin de période scolaire
c'est assez dur
donc on est en train de créer vraiment
il fait parc à l'intérieur même des
cours dit il faut que je vous coupe j'en
suis désolé parce qu'on arrive à la fin
de cette émission
j'en suis vraiment désolé on va écouter
pascal dufresne le candidat de lutte
ouvrière pour faire plaisir aux pros
tragique de la trêve après quelques mois
de campagne sont surprises le bilan à
chalon est le même que dans toutes les
grandes villes les problèmes des
travailleurs c'est d'avoir un emploi de
faire vivre dignement leurs familles
et c'est vrai que ça fait mine de rien
que plusieurs dizaines d'années quand on
subit la précarité les problèmes de
santé les problèmes sur les retraites un
dernièrement et puis des attaques sur
des plans de licenciements qui ont
dégradé la vie des travailleurs de
chalon est dégradé les quartiers uni si
nous sommes aux aubépins c'en est la
preuve vivante et bien moi je veux dire
que finalement ce qui sera important
dans cette élection c'est qu'il faut que
le camp des travailleurs se fasse en
temps
parce que voter lutte ouvrière ça voudra
dire que les travailleurs sont
conscients qu'ils aimeraient guerre qui
nous est menée par les patronats les
hommes politiques qui soutiennent leur
politique qu'il faudra y faire face et
ça sera aussi une façon de dire que les
travailleurs sont pas dupe de tout ce
petit cirque électoral qu'ils ont pas
envie d'y participer et qui pensent que
le bulletin de vote c'est pas ça qui va
changer leur vie mais bien au contraire
une mobilisation collective
allez une minute pour conclure dans
cette émission là tirés au sort avant
les avant le début nathalie leblanc stop
la liste cultivant chalon c'est une
liste de gauche c'est une liste de
chalonnaise et de chalonnais qui sont
très impliqués dans leur ville qu'ils
sont extrêmement motivés nous aimons
chalon
nous voulons nous impliquer pour chalon
c'est un territoire dans lequel nous
avons conçu confiance nous avons
confiance dans le talent des habitants
de notre ville nous voulons travailler
pour l'ensemble des quartiers de la
ville nous voulons travailler pour tout
les chalonnaises et tous les chalonnais
et avec eux on n'a pas suffisamment
parlé d' implication citoyenne c'est un
volet fort de notre programme cultiver
pour une ville plus verte et sécurisé je
n'ai pas pu venir mais c'est important
c'est primordial
cultiver pour redevenir une ville
rayonnante culturellement cultiver parce
que c'est élevé c'est accompagner les
enfants c'est accompagner les jeunes
vers l'autonomie cultiver s'est soigné
et personnes âgées les plus fragiles et
plus précaires cultiver c'est développer
le territoire cultiver ses fertiliser la
terre et donc nous nous engageons nous
nous engageons à faire de chalon une
ville plus citoyenne plus verte serre et
plus durable vous êtes vous couper ses
voix spectrale et à isabelle 2 shon même
combat même exercice éminemment
alors au nom de la liste chaque jour
chalon simplement rappelé qu'une
campagne c'est surtout la rencontre
d'une équipe avec les habitants autour
d'un projet de vie autour d'un projet de
ville nous avons fait le choix de
présenter notre programme depuis le 21
décembre et force a été de constater
qu'il a fait des émules parce que bon
nombre de nos propositions se retrouve
chez nos concurrents alors rassurez vous
on a pris ça comme une marque de
reconnaissance de notre travail notre
projet nous l'avons placée sous le signe
du développement durable qui va bien au
delà de l'écologie ou simplement de
verdir des rues ou des pneus ou des eaux
des places et non par effet de mode mais
parce que chacun doit pouvoir apporter
sa pierre à l'édifice et les
collectivités en premier lieu nous avons
se construit ce programme aussi sur la
base de socle ford la liberté
d'expression le travail le mérite la
solidarité l'équité de traitement afin
que personne ne soit oublié ou méprisés
et enfin une ville appartient à ses
habitants
j'ai donc souhaité rassembler autour
d'un projet et si nous n'avons pas
d'étiquette
mais je pense que j'ai droit quand même
un bon temps de parole d'autant la
conclusion faisait minutes j'en suis
désolé et en fait on l'émission va être
coupé si vous restez vous avez fixé
parce que nous sommes aussi le reflet de
l'équipe et je veux non je suis obligé
de vous arrêter sinon les autres parcs
seront pas à la route rocailleuse parce
que désolé alors chercher des cherche à
donner ma candidature et celle de
l'équipe qui m'entoure c'est d'abord une
passion nous aimons chalon une ville qui
sait accueillir qui s'est intégré une
ville généreuse une ville ouverte
solidaire et humaniste
nous croyons au dépassement des clivages
politiques au service de notre ville
nous préférons plutôt rassembler que
divisés alors notre équipe avec une
moyenne d'âge de 45 ans représentant
l'ensemble des quartiers toutes les
catégories socioprofessionnelles c'est
d'abord une liste de renouvellement de
la jeunesse et aussi de la diversité
notre ambition c'est d'aller chercher
chacun d'entre vous exclus de la
politique
notre démarche repose sur vous car
chacun est expert de sa rue et de son
quartier avec nous il est temps
d'engager une profonde transformation de
la gouvernance de cette ville est en
tout cas il est temps que ensemble
chalon redevienne une ville d'à lens
franck diop alors tout simplement notre
notre ambition est très simple c'est de
remettre
chaque chalonnais dans chalon peu
importe son origine peu importe son sens
son quartier peu importe sans son métier
peu importe d'où il vient en général
c'est de redevenir une ville ambitieuse
de redevenir des quartiers ambitieux que
chacun prenne part au débat au débat
citoyen parce que ça c'est le plus
important remettent encore une fois de
l'humain dans tout ce qui se passe
justement dans la ville que chacun
justement prennent conscience que chalon
est une ville justement qui a largement
les capacités de redevenir une ville
dynamique un phare notamment pour une
région qui est la bresse qui est très
important justement et qui peut
justement ramener un vrai développement
global avec justement des vraies idées
novatrices
voilà merci franck d'objets platret je
sais pas si j'ai envie de conclure en
fait j'ai je vais vous dire un mot alors
c'est vrai qu'on aurait pu aborder plein
d'autres celui-là le sujet humain il est
il est central il a été évoqué mais pas
plus moi dans l'expérience de six années
de mandat ce que je retiens c'est sans
doute les milliers de rencontres on a
eut reçu 2000 personnes en mairie dans
le cadre du maire en direct sans rendez
vous préalable et des milliers d'autres
sur le terrain c'est ce besoin de lien
social que nous avons au fond de nous
mêmes et que notre société un peu trop
individualiste ne nous permet pas donc
on veut vraiment mettre l'accent sur ce
mandat sur le lien vis-à-vis des seniors
vis-à-vis des familles en difficulté
vis-à-vis de chacune et de chacun pour
vivre sa ville à fond alors il faut une
équipe pour le faire cette équipe
les chalonnais la connaisse c'est celle
qui depuis six ans avec sébastien martin
avec un certain nombre d'élus qui se
représentent et d'autres qui arrivent
malade je la ville et essaye de donner
une vision claire renouvellement
embellissement lien social
c'est ça l'enjeu des six années qui
viennent et si nous avons tenu cette
ligne est bien ma foi je pense que nous
aurons rempli de contrat et surtout
qu'on aura fini avant la 60e secondes
merci mourad la wes autres conclut 0 oui
merci cherche à donner à des chalonnais
le 15 mars
je vous invite à voter pour bien vivre à
chalon 2020 la liste écologiste et
citoyenne
la seule capable de relever le défi
climatique
face à cette urgence il faut de courage
politique de la vision de la
détermination
sans écologistes il n'ya pas d'écologie
avec mes colistiers
nous portons des solutions concrètes qui
fonctionne en france et ailleurs
si si des solutions pour se nourrir
sainement respirer un air sain se loger
dignement se déplacer en sécurité des
solutions pour des emplois locaux à
responsable durables et non
délocalisables des solutions pour une
ville plus verte plus solidaire plus
démocratique
avec notre projet audacieux mais
réaliste vous pouvez changer votre ville
elle a fait rentrer enfin dans le 21e
siècle nous le ferons ensemble
naturellement voilà ma conclusion
merci moi la west merci à tous les six
nous voilà au terme de ce débat d'être
venu jouer le jeu difficile compliqué et
très contraint de l'expression
démocratique merci thomas c'est un
plaisir
merci à vous c'était très bien